Playing Candy Crush will make you kill a man.
Truth?
Or an incredibly over-sensationalised cold
open to a story about videogames and violence?
Hey guys, Joe Bereta here guest hosting for
DNews.
The world of science hath graced us with yet
another study concerning the correlation betwixt
violence in videogames and violence in real
life, but stick with me button mashers, because
this isn't your garden variety violent content
does or doesn't beget evil in your impressionable
young child type of story.
Now, first off, lets all agree that aggression
is a very common byproduct of playing video
games.
It doesn't happen all the time, but it can
rear its ugly, hostile head occasionally.
Like...
I swear to all the gods that if I get blue-shelled
again because I'm in first place in Mario
Kart Wii, I'm gonna murder everything.
The game punishes you for being awesome and
encourages mediocrity.
It doesn't make sense.
Moving on, research coming out of Oxford University
postulates that it isn't graphic, bloody headshots,
spinal-cord snaps, or gruesome koopa-troopa
curb stomps that generate aggresive/violent
behavior in players.
The root of the evil actually lies in the
failure and frustration that a human experiences
when gaming.
So, instead of focusing just on the content
and storylines of games, these guys also monitored
the psychological side of, basically, trying
to complete a task... which is trying to beat
the game, or finish the level, or get that
god-forsaken flappy bird past the fourth pipe.
It's basic human nature to want to succeed
and be great at things, and when you're losing,
over and over again, it makes sense that emotions
might go all Dante's peak.
It doesn't matter if you're trying to finish
a dude off by ripping him in half in Mortal
Kombat or clear a screen in Minesweeper, if
you suck...it sucks.
Co-author of the study, Richard Ryan, explains,
"When people feel they have no control over
the outcome of a game, that leads to aggression.
We saw that in our experiments.
If you press someone's competencies, they'll
become more aggressive, and our effects held
up whether the games were violent or not."
So, these Oxfordians rounded-up 600 college-aged
humans and scienced them with video game experiments.
Utilizing violent and non-violent games, the
researchers manipulated variables, like difficulty
settings and in one particular exercise, participants
were asked to submerge their hands in super
cold water, like painfully cold.
Unbeknownst to them, everyone did it for the
same amount of time.
They then played a round of Tetris, afterwhich,
they were to assign an amount of time for
the next guy or gal to keep their hands submerged.
Now, get this sadistic little tid-bit: Players
who experienced the more difficult version
of Russian Block Stacking assigned, on average,
10 seconds more chilly hand-bath time to the
next player.
Crazy.
So videogames probably won't send you on a
murder rampage, but they might turn you into
a momentary butthole.
One time, I threw my best friends Snake Eyes
GI Joe at the wall, causing bits of molded
plastic to explode everywhere, spewing forth
a plume of imagination and nostalgia.
It's not cause I'm a bad person, it's because
I was playing Battletoads.
Richard Ryan also said, "When the experience
involves threats to our ego, it can cause
us to be hostile and mean to others."
And really, doesn't this apply to all facets
of our lives?
No one wants to look stupid or feel inadequate.
Those feelings can lead to insecurity, or
embarrassment, or pure, unadulterated wrath.
That's why we have real life, rage-quitting
instances of full-grown adults throwing second
base into center-field and flying monopoly
boards on family game night... and the one
time I saw my own mother try to bite through
the cord of an NES controller because Super
Mario Brothers brought her to a dark dark
place.
Guys, what's your most frustrating video game
moment?
Describe it with vivid detail down below.
Thanks for watching DNews, my name's Joe Bereta.
You can find me over at youtube.com/sourcefed
or youtube.com/baratsandbereta.
Have a wonderful rage-free day.